on a vu ces vols de données personnelles
chez desjardins est aussi capital one
cette semaine qui avait dû agir
ottawa veut enquêter mon se pose la
question qui véritablement va protéger
nos données personnelles deux
spécialistes sont avec tous michel
carlos également jean-philippe décarie
mme mathieu j'ai lu dans une entrevue
d'ailleurs que vous avez donné qu'il ya
20 ans on disait déjà que le vol
d'identité c'était le crime de l'avenir
tous les deux d'ailleurs qu'est ce qu'on
a fait concrètement depuis maison c'est
justement ne pas faire assez c'est que
des légendes cesser les crimes de
l'armée mais concrètement ça jamais été
une priorité
des événements comme desjardins capital
one c'est le temps de prendre les
actions pour vraiment contrer le vol
d'identité et met des des organistes en
place moi je suggère dans les cheminées
parce que les gens les victimes de votre
identité sont dépourvus 6 est ce que
l'on voit levier de capital one day
desjardins ils sont pas dans l'avenir
j'appelle ou pour savoir quoi faire
ils vont appeler leurs institutions
financières vont faire un bout mais les
gens ont besoin d'être sécurisés commun
que je peux prendre action alors et
guichet unique ça soit une bonne
solution
ben on est tellement fort que oui
certainement se passer définitivement
oui c'est sûr puisque les jeux c'est pas
la responsabilité des gens de savoir
d'où ça vient des flux de données comme
celle là il y en a tous les jours depuis
des années à tous les jours tous les
jours bien sûr bien sûr mais c'est pas
quelque chose de nouveau le meilleur
exemple si en fait il est frais de
données comme tous ces défis de données
mais ils sont pas rendus publics même
son pour revendre immédiatement qui ont
une durée de vie extrêmement longues
souvent je pense par exemple que
l'afflux d'aidé massive qui a eu de
l'ensemble des arbres jeu très
personnelles des utilisateurs de
linkedin en 2012 ses sorties en 2016
donc plusieurs années plus tard sa grève
je suis dingue qui raconte yann et mot
de passe des messages personnels des
informations nominatives sur les appuis
sa 35e même plutôt en hausse à vous de
l'argent donc peut-être que la flûte
exemple des jardins et peut-être pas
publics et port-vendres marquette en
ostrevant un peu la zone grise à ce
niveau là au niveau des faits mais ça se
peut que dans quatre cinq ans ça sorte
et que ça fasse énormément des gosses on
la voit derrière la question que justin
vaïsse i qui est du placés pour nous
protéger et protéger nos données
personnelles nous mêmes c'est bête à
dire mais c'est la personne elle-même en
premier on a besoin légier numérique ont
prédit ces vases et fait qu'est ce qu'on
peut dire qu'ils jettent ils étaient
tout le temps les mêmes mots de passe
les mêmes identifiants et ont toutes
leur cellule à une autre temps même
placé leur meneur de changer les mots de
passe a tout changé les mots de passe
changé vis densifiant le actuellement
avec votre adresse email et votre
téléphone vous pouvez être victime de
votre nation les fraudeurs même pas
besoin de plus que ça ils vont appeler
une taupe et une téléphone offert un
changement de téléphone ils vont prendre
le contrôle de votre téléphone d'un
principe ils vont prendre le contrôle de
vous donnez donc ccfa fait le ménage
dans le fond qui vient placer une
protégée ce soit que oui les numériques
supports importants mais je suis tout le
problème aussi de conflit ces ensembles
de données personnelles l'extra personne
puisque est extrapolé nos données
personnelles comme les accusations les
débats les cotes de crédit par exemple
que d'equifax on souvient m
mais les habitudes de consommation
aussitôt ces données long les confier à
des compagnies privées externe souvent
merkel dont le but premier de maximiser
leurs profits pas d'une sa main de
protéger ses informations le nokia
oui on est responsable de ce qu'on peut
contrôler certainement mais il ya une
responsabilité de l'apport de ces
entreprises là aussi puis je prends le
bus le facebook commence à ramasser des
amants assez salée merci mais au 2e saut
sont rendus le budget et ces amendes le
manque d'argent est ce que la solution
passerait par un lot législatif et si
madrid ou drôlement québécois également
qui veut regrouper nos informations
personnelles mais à peu près quoi 80%
des ces informations là qu'on enverrait
chez des entreprises
vous l'avez dit tout à l'heure amazon a
et b mcg est ce que vous trouvez qu'il
ya des dangers par rapport à ce gars là
mais sont en conflit devenir un
organisme extérieur privé qui à
l'extérieur du canada
il ya un risque certain pu dans le fond
plus qu'elle est que beaucoup de données
une masse de données
si une brèche dans ce système là
imaginer c'est 80% des informations des
citoyens du québec puis un bris de
sécurité aux fournisseurs de services sa
voix est épouvantable
votre opinion là dessus c'est un point
singly d'échec moi quand j'entends ce
que le gouvernement joue jamais donné
c'est un réflexe professionnel mais ça
me fait peur un peu la gestion de tout
ce qui compterait informatique au niveau
de l'état et du gouvernement
historiquement ça a été un échec faut le
dire c'est dommage j'aimerais ça soit
mieux consommer les cerveaux surtout
privés sont pas au gouvernement c'est
pour cela les conditions les consciences
en arrière les conditions avantages
sociaux cds copie privée ils vont aller
chercher desservons les spéciales
sensible à s'occuper d'abord il ya ne
serait plus au gouvernement
c'est ça le problème brièvement aussi
ottawa qui veut arrêter est ce que ta
voix devrait avoir plus de dents plus de
sanctions pour les entreprises qui font
preuve de laxisme c'est définitif
sauvegarder les amendes qui aux états
unis au royaume uni à nova et ça prend
des amendes plus sévères mais je regarde
au niveau des routes serait temps d'en
section financière pourrait prendre un
certain et lille comme ça avait privé
pour dire qu'est ce qu'on peut mettre en
place pour mettre des systèmes pour
protéger des citoyens à ce moment de
donner un service ou six fois les
recommandations du rapport commun table
était le mot questionnement par rapport
à ça c'est que je crois que de ron
initiative législative la part des lits
schlatter de dalida les anciens certains
contrôles notamment ses grosses
entreprises le qui ont énormément de
données personnelles mais c'est souvent
des états qui vont se buter à des
entreprises qui ont le chiffre
d'affaires est plus élevé qu'à propre
pib donc sans faute mais le rapport de
force il pas exactement la danse est
extrêmement problématique quand on sait
justement que facebook plus budget une
amende de 5 milliards puis que le
contrôle exercé et - là dessus ils ont
une influence indue sur l'ensemble de la
société
c'est peut-être la solution le
ou du moins une piste de solution
l'aspect législatif mais à quel point il
sera en effet je sais pas reste à voir
merci beaucoup à tous les deux michel
carlos ex-chef ex quoi des crimes
économiques à la sûreté du québec est
aussi joffre les décarie médecin chef de
la cybersécurité commissionnaires du
québec
très intéressant merci complaisez